hey this is presh talwalkar
two candles of equal heights but
different thicknesses are lit
the first burns off in eight hours and
the second in ten hours
how long after lighting in hours will
the first candle be half the height of
the second candle
the candles are lit simultaneously and
each burns at a constant linear rate
i thank ryan from india for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
we can visualize the solution with the
help of a graph
let the vertical axis be the height of
the candle at a particular time and let
the x axis be the time that has elapsed
the first candle burns off in 8 hours
and the second candle burns off in 10
hours
each starts at the same height so we can
draw line segments from that same
starting point to the x-axis
the slope of the first line is negative
h over eight and the slope of the second
line is negative h over ten
so we can write equations for each of
these lines
the first line will be y one is equal to
negative h over eight multiplied by x
plus h and the second will be y two is
equal to negative h over ten multiplied
by x plus h
we want the time at which this line
segment is exactly equal to this line
segment that is the first candle is half
the height of the second candle
let's solve this algebraically
the second candle is exactly twice the
height of the first candle so y2 is
equal to 2 y1
we can substitute in and then we will
simplify each side of the equation
from here we can factor out an h term
from each side
let's continue to simplify this equation
since each side has a factor of h
the h will cancel out so it doesn't
depend on the initial height of the
candles
we then have negative x over ten plus
one is equal to negative x over four
plus two
we can then group like terms
one over 4 minus 1 over 10 is equal to 3
over 20.
we multiply both sides by 20 over 3 and
we get the answer that x is equal to 20
over 3 hours which is equal to 6 hours
and 40 minutes and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time